like tvs from great britain
yazid three i noticed again and again
that i still haven't
watched it
so let's play a simple advantages
together with you six maybe later
french i know that i read
a bit from before
the advance variant still have on
with  the most pleasant of all
the things that can come
so
ok
very typical position for this the
advance variant
knows and I also no longer
like to swap the clock with loose
b54 to the
7 he now
lets do it like that  as long as it
lasts something like that will also arrive the next few moves a bit if he
helps a bit
then black and could already
stand really well and the runners exchange
a cd white field ring and as a result the
abi 3 has drawn maybe I have
because they  idea runner a3 and then it
doesn't come well to the finish line
it's quite natural to prevent it oh god
those are d  ann but out of
surprise yes now i have the
finish line or
well he can of course
can play the game but now
i have every grip
yes i thought so too but
it looks somehow now if that is
really weakening
so lady  so let's take
two
vidic the i3
with 31 yes but that has to be a good one
game
at least in any case a good ending
game maybe i have something
else to
do like two you could also play
if he then probably has to
swap then swap
springer we filled a
bit
a bit the meditating move then
not even
like that and now gets c2
wants to open I
still stand by
it so what does he have then too than he can so
d5 or so
so d5 edicto.de I have four  Do I
have the schachner or tom harvey or
chess when he actually has
no square for the tunnel not a good one
okay
why simplified it a bit  yes,
that he was the processing here was was was
very funny
so if the atmosphere is a
bit uncomfortable a bit but
I don't know maybe already play c2 or
something
or something else here
yes okay of course I could
still run the three or  or
do something like that
or maybe a 44 is maybe also
an idea
how to come up with the two yourself
probably and then i no
longer have the possibility to break in with the lady from
the fifth end
but probably
something went wrong at some point before that
but what should  not so
bad here but now again
after eleven moves lasted